okay hello everybody
so I'm gonna go ahead and share my
screen as I have a presentation
um so today I'll be running through
crypto entrepreneurship 101 and it's
going to be
um so please
make sure that this is coming up okay on
the screen for everybody
are we all good can I get some
information yeah it looks good we can
see it excellent excellent cool all
right so I've got a pretty tight
timeline so I'm gonna try to move
quickly
um and I may end up having to jump over
some slides in case I run out of time
but let's go ahead and run through
things so
I'm Steve Qureshi I'm a crypto VC I used
to be a professional poker player as
could mentioned a software engineer and
a startup founder and I've been
investing professionally in crypto for
over five years so I know what I'm
talking about I've been in this industry
for quite a while seen a lot of ups and
downs uh we're on a down lately uh I'm
sure those of you who are in this course
uh can't help but notice that crypto has
been through a pretty crazy sentiment
shift within the last year
um and we're gonna be talking about that
because I think that's part and parcel
of what makes crypto entrepreneurship
very different than other kinds of
Entrepreneurship
so high level review what I'm talking
about today first I'm going to give you
a sort of thousand foot view of startups
and how I think about startups and I
think how how you should be thinking
about startups if you're thinking about
coming into the space uh from coming out
of school
second is I want to talk about what
makes crypto startups different than
other kinds of startups
then we're going to go through very very
briefly the steps to starting a great
startup uh and then how to find a good
idea and common mistakes in finding a
good idea for the startup that you're
going to build
Okay so
startups are special
serves are special because they have
magic powers
this is because startups are small
they're Nimble they're unconstrained uh
you know large companies can't do what
startups can do they have a lot more
moves available to them on the
chessboard than a a big company does a
big company is a lot more like uh you
know a lot more like a pond it can only
really move in One Direction it has you
know some core product that it has to
defend or has margins that they have to
take care of uh they have a lot more
regulatory constraints but startups are
not like that because they're small
they're Nimble they're they're like a
queen they can take many different moves
they can take all sorts of risks they're
they're courageous and most of all
startups are innovative this allows
startups to do things that other
companies cannot do it allows them to
take risks that other companies cannot
take and that allows them to move into
fields or move into industries that
other bigger companies cannot move into
so startups can do amazing things
but most startups don't do amazing
things
it's important to understand this if
you're thinking about startups startups
are stressful
each of you to understand if you are
thinking about potentially starting a
startup okay so this this chart right
here shows for each funding round the
failure to raise the following round of
funding okay so if you raise a seed
round that means your likelihood of
raising your series a is 20 the inverse
of this you know 79.4 percent if you're
in series a your Chancellor is series B
is 50 if you raise the serious B your
chance to raise series C is 45 and so on
and it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller over time
which means that if you are if you raise
your seed round okay which is not easy
to do you raise the seed round from a
professional DC
your chance of making it to exit an exit
in this case means that you made it all
the way through the Journey and you got
either an acquisition or an IPO
your chance of making it to an exit from
a seed round is three percent
your chance to making it from a series A
is 11. your chance to make it from a
series B is 16 percent
from series C is 20 percent
this means that even if you achieve what
is pretty difficult within the contest
of all startups to get funded by
professor professional VCS still your
likelihood of making it through is very
low
it's important to understand this most
startups fail
this means most people should not start
startups because if you start a startup
you will probably fail and you will
almost certainly not become rich
now you cannot but notice that as you
look around you see all sorts of people
telling you that starting a startup is
the coolest thing you can possibly do
and then if you start a startup you're
going to be so awesome you're going to
start something great you're so
brilliant you have all these wonderful
ideas
um and you know there's a whole cottage
industry that has really spun up around
this idea of selling the story a about
how great it is how romantic how
impressive it is to be a startup founder
and you know you guys are at Stanford
I'm sure that you breathe this air more
than anybody else at pretty much any
other school you know my understanding
is that at Stanford basically the two
coolest things you can be number one is
being a College Dropout and the number
two is being a startup founder
I think as if you see it's in common I
need to to underline this which is that
startups won't make you cool
uh they won't make you rich
they will challenge you they will stress
you out and they will take away years of
your life most people who build startups
are not going to get that much out of
them and another important thing that
I like to reiterate to people who are
thinking about coming to startups is
that there's a common view among people
who are considering startups
that startups even if you fail even if
you don't succeed that starting a
startup is going to be good for you
because it's going to teach you all
these skills it's going to make you it's
just going to make you a more worldly
person or give you some set of
experiences that are that are that are
valuable
um and what I want to say is that uh
that's kind of
and the way what I mean by that kind of
is that the most valuable thing
that you get out of startups is having a
chance of success if you build a
successful startup you will learn a
tremendous amount you will learn so much
about about scaling about managing
people about Revenue about product about
customer management about you know
customer support all these different
things that you will you will you'll be
forced to learn about it's incredible
education there's really nothing like it
um but building a startup that goes
nowhere
building a startup that nobody wants
building a startup that mostly it's you
shouting into the void and nobody
listening doesn't teach you very much at
all it's mostly just a waste of your
time and energy and of course a waste of
other people's money
and although you may be able to start a
startup and then get a job as a product
manager somewhere if the company fails
um and maybe you'll get a couple good
relationships out of it you know to be
honest starting startups that don't go
anywhere doesn't teach you very much
it's not a very valuable way to spend
your time or your energy so that's why I
think it is very important I I'm not
trying to say
but you shouldn't start a startup what
I'm trying to do is I'm trying to scare
you
because I think it's important to be
scared of startups um you should be
scared of starting a startup there's
only one good reason to start a startup
and that is because you want to solve a
big problem with your life and you are
willing to sacrifice time and energy
for a chance habit for a chance
it will probably not work out
and if you start a startup you should
understand that in your bones that most
likely this will not work out but for a
chance at getting something right a
chance at building something big
changing something with your life with
your career with your time that that is
worth it to you that is the reason why
you should start a startup
now that being said it can't escape you
that uh many people who start startups
end up becoming incredibly wealthy
incredibly Rich
um and so you it begs the question why
are startups so valuable if what I'm
saying is true and most startups tend to
fail why is it that so many people so
many ideas so much culture is pushing
you to this idea of like like hey you
should start a startup
um in fact some of the most valuable
companies in the world today are
startups and and the value of these
startups have grown tremendously over
the last 10 years uh now some of these
valuations have obviously pulled back if
you've been paying attention to what's
happening last year there's a these are
stale numbers from April but um it's
certainly still the case that these
these these startups or these you know
private companies are tremendously
valuable and they've grown incredibly
quickly
the reason for this is that not all
Innovation comes from startups but a lot
of it does a lot of companies that you
are likely familiar with you know
products like Google Maps doubleclick
which manages the the uh the ad options
for Google Instagram Android PayPal
YouTube these companies were all
startups
these companies were all startups that
were acquired by bigger companies you
know in the case of some of these Google
in the case of some of these it was
Facebook these were all companies that
were acquired at some point and those
Acquisitions led to them becoming very
very successful products so
let's zoom out for a second and think
more bigger picture why is it that
startups are so important and why is it
that if you do build a successful
startup then you will get rewarded in
such a big way for building a successful
startup
the answer is because most economic
growth comes from innovation
Innovation means finding new ways to do
things better than the old ways that we
did things right so basically taking
Innovation fundamentally what it does is
allows you to take the same inputs the
same raw materials and get better output
for it that's Innovation it's
improvements in
the underlying process of making stuff
that we care about
now in a world of declining growth and
in declining interest rates Innovation
is extremely valuable it's one of the
only valuable things that we have left
in a world where we're not making more
people
and um you know interest rates are going
down now you obviously have noticed
interest rates have gone up over the
last year but actually
real rates uh so real rates are the
difference between the nominal interest
rate which is the number that you see
you know at the FED funds rate which is
oh you know it's almost five percent
um but of course if inflation is five
percent or higher than five percent then
actually real interest rates which are
what you get when you take the nominal
interest rate you subtract the the
inflation rate
um
that is actually negative right now it's
it's actually we're still real rates are
are still very negative which is what
they were uh three years ago as well
so now if you if you if you zoom out a
bit okay ignore the the recent you know
kind of uh inflationary events that have
been happening lately if you if you zoom
out and look over the last you know
700 years
interest rates have been going down for
as long as we can possibly measure it
that's a very important fact to
understand interest rates have been
going down for as long as we can
possibly measure it and when I'm talking
about interest rates I mean both nominal
and real interest rates okay now what is
an interest rate it's important to
understand what what do I mean when I
say this an interest rate is the
opportunity cost of capital mean that if
I don't give this money to you
how much could I get for that money
elsewhere that's the interest rate the
interest rate is what is the value of
compounding this money if I don't take
any risk with it or if I take a minimal
amount of risk with it so
um as a as a startup founder
in order for you to build a startup
that's worth funding the growth rate of
your startup must be better than the
prevailing interest rate I mean that you
must give me better risk adjusted
returns than what I could get doing
something much much safer right putting
money into you know loaning it to the US
government or loaning it to a very very
safe Corporation okay so if that
interest rate has been getting lower and
lower and lower over time
another way of putting that is that we
have run out of of great ideas
of what to do with money so we have a
lot of money we have a lot of resources
we have a lot of capital
but we don't have a lot of good ideas
good ideas give you return on investment
they give you return on Capital and if
you're running out of good ideas if you
have more resources than you have ideas
then that means ideas are becoming more
valuable when the interest rate goes
down that tells you ideas are more
valuable that means we're hurting for
Innovation we want more Innovation and
we can't find it that is why over time
more and more Capital has been chasing
innovation
because of the fact that interest rates
have been trending downwards for the
last several hundred years
and so if it's true that most of that
Innovation comes from startups that
means most that Innovation is coming
from people like you
and of course there's a lot of money
chasing startups and you can't help but
notice that as well uh now you know
these valuations have come down over the
last year as there's been a broad
correction in equity markets and
especially in Risk assets but the trend
line Remains unabated the trend line you
can see over time is that there's more
and more money going into venture
capital and venture capital is kind of
the seat of where Innovation happens
it's a very very earliest stages of
innovation so whether it's seed rounds
that have gone from you know 10 years
ago seed rounds you know the uh what is
this this is the median the median seed
round was six hundred thousand now the
median seed round is 2.5 million and
series a the median series a ten years
ago with six million now it's 15 million
so what that tells you is that these
rounds these funding rounds are getting
bigger and the valuations for these
companies are getting bigger because
people are more starved for growth
so that is why from a very very high
level if you are successful in building
a startup the rewards can be immense now
of course you probably won't be
successful that's okay you can still
take this class but it's important to
understand why this stuff matters and
why this stuff is being rewarded by the
market in a way that it wasn't
previously why is it that your parents
or your grandparents weren't talking
about startups all the time but we are
and the answer at a very very broad
level
is I mean there are a bunch of micro
reasons but the macro reason is that
interest rates are down growth is down
population growth has decreased and
that's a lot of the reason why startups
have become more and more important over
time and why we or why you as young
people should be spending more of your
time thinking about Innovation and
startups okay
so that's a that's a very very high
level uh understanding that I think it's
useful to communicate and that concludes
the pep talk about startups generally
let's dive now into the meat of it and
talk about crypto
how are crypto startups different from
normal startups okay and by the way I'm
going to be calling it crypto I'm not
going to be calling it web3 just FYI you
know if you prefer the term with me just
sub that in when I when I say crypto so
first thing to understand crypto
startups are subversive okay they have
many enemies at many different uh in
many different jurisdictions around the
world uh there are many companies that
have banned crypto of course uh China
being the the most significant among
them
um but you know mostly countries that
aren't very heavy on Capital controls
the SEC you know Gary Gensler the head
of the SEC has made very clear he's not
a big fan of crypto
um and although you know there's there's
mixed reception of crypto in most
governments and in most places
um although there is mixed reception of
crypto let me turn my video back on
let's see here
okay cool
um although there is mixed reception of
crypto in many places around the world
and among many Regulators around the
world
um you know crypto startups it's one of
the few industries that you're going to
work with that you are going to have to
wonder
um is what I'm doing illegal are
Regulators going to come after me most
startups most things that you build you
will not have this problem but in crypto
you will you do have to think about law
and Regulation and you know all the
different jurisdictions in which you're
going to be operating if you build a
crypto startup and of course we're going
to have some lectures later on in this
course that are going to address that
next thing about crypto of course that
crypto is extremely volatile
um you know obviously everything has
been volatile in the last year so across
2022 you saw you know a bunch of very
very small world public companies like
you know meta and uh you know the PayPal
and uh you know Netflix and companies
like that have very very steep drawdowns
as did the s p and the NASDAQ itself uh
but crypto has been doing this for a
while crypto has had very very steep uh
drawdowns as well as upswings over the
last
you know basically five six years so uh
or since Inception but most notably you
can see it in the chart over the last
five six years
um so this is just part and parcel of
how crypto works and so when you see
okay wow crypto prices are quite low
from where they were two years ago yes
that's been true almost every single
year uh there's always been a view that
crypto is volatile and it's just part of
it's part of the game and I don't think
that's something that's going to go away
even over the next few years
this is volatility makes it difficult to
tell what does real product Market fit
uh product Market fit is a term that
means you know is this product actually
what the market wants meaning that you
know is this thing ready to scale is
this thing really uh have we have we
cracked the code of building a great
product that's going to fly off the
shelf so to speak
um it's difficult to ascertain that when
prices are super random and they're all
over the place but that is very much uh
the case in crypto and something that
you have to be mindful of
the next thing about crypto that's
that's quite different is that crypto uh
service or open source and they're very
public by that nature
um when you're building in crypto
startups you are on Twitter all the time
you have your you very often you have a
telegram you might be on WeChat you
might have your own open source uh repo
that anybody is uh uh anybody is playing
around with and interacting with even
before you're ready to go mainstream so
that means that in crypto startups
Community is everything and this is a
lot of implications on strategy which
I'm sure you guys are going to get to
later on in the course
now
if you want to build a startup in crypto
there are basically a few big steps that
I think you have to you have to kind of
get through in order in order to build a
great startup in crypto
so the first thing
is you want to make sure that you first
learn
you need to learn the culture the
products and the history of the sector
you don't want to just say hey I love
crypto and I have this great idea that I
you know thought up in a dream so I'm
going to go and build this thing okay
very strongly do not recommend doing
that crypto is a very complex field it's
one where a lot of intuitions are not
going to serve you well in crypto
because there are a bunch of things in
crypto that are not intuitive in which
case the most important thing to do is
to really make sure that you take the
time to learn what came before you what
works what doesn't and and why is it
that crypto uh you know sort of works or
doesn't work the way that it does
second
um is that it's very important to find
great co-founders finding great
co-founders is difficult uh there are
certain places that I think I would
recommend to find co-founders and others
where I would not
um then you want to come up with a great
idea so coming up with great ideas hard
we're going to talk in more detail about
how to find the great idea and how to
validate it and then of course the last
step is to raise money for that idea
from a VC like myself or like uh a local
I know you guys
heard from earlier so Step One Is to
learn
do you know enough to start a startup
the answer usually if you're at the very
very beginning of your startup turning
the answer is usually no you don't know
enough to start a startup and you need
to take some time to immerse yourself in
the culture immerse yourself in the
products and the history of the industry
that you're working in
um so I you know I would generally
recommend that if you are not very
situated in crypto you don't know crypto
very well spend a lot of time playing
around with products you know make a
list for yourself of all the things that
are in the sector that you're working in
if you're working in D5 you're working
in infrastructure go try out every
single product you can think of that
matters in that space get to know the
history of the products that are in that
space talk to people who are working on
those products or who use those products
and build an understanding of what they
care about and why these things are
built the way they're built
now the best way to do that is actually
join another web3 startup so I consider
this to be the best education you can
get in startups that it's what I did
before I founded my own startup is go
work for a startup
if you were at a startup one you were
going to be surrounded by people who are
very often going to be great potential
co-founders two you will absolutely be
immersed in the culture of the products
of the space three you will have a much
deeper understanding of what do people
in this industry care about how do they
think how do they talk how do they walk
all those things are going to be
instructive to giving you the mental
models that you need in order to
figure out what is worth building and
what is a waste of time and energy
read voraciously go to meetups and
hackathons play around with the tech you
know read newsletters follow people on
Twitter you know get yourself into the
knowledge graph of what people are
thinking about and talking about in that
particular space and if you are
technical get technical at least a
little bit right so even if you are hey
I'm the BD guy or I'm the you know
something else uh spend if you know look
if you don't know
um if you don't know how to how well
let's say this if you don't have
solidity learn solidity uh if you don't
know how to use a block Explorer learn
how to use a block Explorer right if you
don't even know how to code even the
very very basics of you know python just
learn a little bit of python any
marginal Improvement you can make in
your own technicality is going to help
you in being better equipped to be able
to start a startup and think clearly
about how to solve important engineering
problems that you're going to face as a
startup founder
okay once you do that
it's time to assemble a team
the best teams are composer friends okay
a lot of people when it comes to
founding startups they think about oh
you know I want to do some co-founder
dating thing they go to some co-founder
group or some you know I want to found a
company
um you know lunches or whatever I I
don't think these are great ways to find
uh co-founders co-founders are very very
deep in Intimate Relationships um
they're it's very hard to find somebody
who's going to be a good co-founder to
you and the number one cause of company
failures is co-founder breakups so it's
important to recognize that this is
actually a very big risk to your startup
is that you pick somebody who is the
wrong partner for you and it's going to
result in Wasted Years of your life
wasted you know energy wasted money
um it's incredibly incredibly common and
I can't caution against this enough to
be thoughtful about how you choose your
co-founder it's important to understand
even if you find somebody who you want
to start something with you don't have
to jump directly into starting a company
with them I I very strongly recommend if
you have somebody with whom you want to
start a startup work on a small project
do some Consulting together especially
if it's something that you can charge
money for because money is the number
one thing that's going to bring out
personality differences and or
differences in working styles with
somebody who you potentially want to
found something with so if you want to
use somebody as a co-founder or pick
somebody as a co-founder you want to
pick somebody who you trust with your
life somebody who's competent somebody's
resourceful somebody compliments you
um the the famous uh turn of phrase is
that you want to find somebody who
reminds you of James Bond
somebody who you could drop into any
situation anywhere and you feel like
they would manage to to be okay and make
their way out that's the kind of person
you want to look for when it comes to
finding somebody to found a company with
now
some people say like look I want to be a
solo founder that's okay there are some
great solo Founders in crypto who've
been very successful but generally
speaking most teams uh have more than
one founder usually the answer is two to
four uh more than four tends to be too
unwieldy and then you know there's
disputes over who's actually pulling
their weight so generally speaking four
is the most that you want to have in
terms of co-founders
um two is usually uh two or three is
usually the the most standard number
um solo can work but it's more difficult
and look starting startups is hard and I
don't know that you'd want to do it
alone uh just because it's it's just
more psychologically challenging to have
nobody else there with you to help pull
the weight especially the very beginning
uh but one thing that you do want to
understand if you are not a solo founder
is who's the CEO
it's very important to decide this up
front and not have this be a point of
contention later on down the road and
usually it should be easy to figure out
who's a CEO one of the two people should
jump out at you as being like hey this
person should be the CEO this now it's
important to also uh respect that the
CEO does not mean this is the more
important person
the CEO is a particular job this job is
the job that is going to be responding
to investors is going to be signing the
papers is going to be doing the
fundraising is going to be the sort of
figurehead uh for the company now
different CEOs do different things
they're product CEOs they're Business
Development CEOs they're sales CEOs so
it really depends on what the CEO is
going to be doing and what the
particular company is
um but if you if you don't know who the
CEO is by the time you're raising money
that's a very big red flag and it
usually means there's a fight waiting to
happen and you know your your VCS are
not going to be very interested in
funding a fight
also it's important to also think about
Equity splits so let's say that you have
two Founders
um that's not always 50 50. sometimes
it's 50 50 and 50 50 is usually the
default if you don't have another
consideration of how to split the equity
but if somebody is genuinely bringing
more to the table it's totally okay to
have an equity split that's 60 40 or 70
30 or 80 20. um even if you have three
people sometimes one person has 15 the
other two have 25.
um so it depends it depends on what
they're bringing to the table oftentimes
it depends on who is there first who
contributed more IP who's more senior
and more experienced who has some
important consideration that gives them
more negotiating power at the table the
important thing is not that everybody is
equal sometimes they are very often
that's the most common thing is that
everyone's equal but even if they're not
equal the important thing is that
everybody is committed in an agreement
that what happened is fair
that's what's important so make sure you
figure out your Equity splits before you
end up going trying to actually uh raise
money for for a company
and three come up with a great idea
validate the idea is actually great
we're going to talk about this shortly
and then finally raise money and you'll
be hearing about that in later lecture
so
now I'd be remiss if I didn't talk about
FTX because how does FTX change all of
this when we're talking about startups
and raising money right so FTX for those
of you I'm sure all of you are very
familiar especially given that you know
uh Sam has an affiliation with with
Stanford through his parents uh FTX was
one of the largest corporate frauds in
recent history
um one of the one of the biggest perhaps
in corporate history period uh Sam uh
just you know the very very brief story
Sam was a sort of luminary founder he
was he was lauded the world around
um he was on billboards he was on
magazines
um considered to be the youngest uh
youngest billionaire and one of the you
know basically the the youngest uh the
the richest self-made billionaire under
the age of 30.
it turned out he was running a fairly
massive Ponzi scheme where he was taking
deposits at FTX which was a crypto
exchange that he ran and um funneling
those into his Affiliated Market maker
which was losing tons of money uh and
managed to make a bunch of liquid
Investments as well as lose a bunch of
capital uh which lost billions of
dollars worth of customer assets so the
uh the the aftermath of FTX has
triggered a pretty massive regulatory
backlash uh around the world and this of
course affects the prospects for crypto
startups in different ways for different
sectors
um so you know for for if you're
building a layer one protocol uh you're
like building an underlying blockchain
or you're building a D5 protocol I don't
know that actually FTX in retrospect has
that much of an effect on you but if you
want to build a crypto exchange or if
you want to build you know something the
custodies crypto assets on behalf of
users FTX certainly is going to have an
impact on the way in which you have to
build that startup and the way in which
that startups can be treated by
regulators
ultimately when something like FTX
happens it results in a decrease of
trust across the board
and a decrease in trust is bad for
startups now that doesn't mean that this
decrease in trust is going to be
permanent it's not almost always these
things are temporary and eventually
there's a recovery people forget they
move on
um if I had to guess I would take
probably you know call it three to six
months until people mostly are passed
what happened with FTX Regulators are
going to hold on to it for much longer
than um you know sort of retail
investors and institutional investors I
think institutional investors are going
to move on and Retail investors more
quickly but this decrease in trust is a
real thing incentives need trust they
need trust because in order for somebody
to play around with the startup they
have to be willing to take risk right
why are they going to put money into
your startup if they're worried about
even something like coinbase or binance
if they're worried about those companies
why why would they be willing to take a
risk on on you so
startups need that trust and they trust
it'll come back but it takes time and in
the meantime it is going to be more
difficult for startups to operate and
for them to acquire users and acquire
Capital
um over the over the short term
and yet in the last month you've seen
that crypto prices have returned to
Trend in the last month so today is uh
what is this uh January 22nd I think
um in the last 30 days Bitcoin is up
about 35 actually more than that as of
this morning so maybe like 38
um a pretty significant increase in fact
if you look at what happened in crypto
prices over the last year they were
pretty tied to the NASDAQ but he tried
to interest rates and that Trend got
bucked when FTX collapsed you saw a big
drawdown in crypto assets about 15 when
FTX collapsed and it became known that
FTX was a massive fraud but actually in
the last 30 days you've seen a total
recovery and that crypto prices return
back to the trend that they departed
from when FTX went down and now why do I
say that the reason why I say that is
that what that tells you
is that investors basically are saying
look FDX is bad
Sam is a bad man all this stuff is
terrible for startups and that's
unfortunate but our long-term view on
crypto which is ultimately what prices
are expressing they're expressing what
people believe about the value of these
Assets in the future a long-term view
about crypto is basically unchanged
that we basically believe that crypto is
still a valuable thing and we still want
to invest in it we still want to hold it
for the long term despite the fact that
you know FTX turned out to be a massive
fraud because at the end of the day
FTX vindicates why crypto is important
to begin with what crypto is trying to
do is to make it so that you do not have
to rely on other individuals on other
companies on other institutions in order
for you to trust your money
that was the original reason why Satoshi
Nakamoto invented Bitcoin the in the
Bitcoin white paper it says I've
invented a way for you to transact
without the need for trusted third
parties
that is what crypto is all about and
that's ultimately what FTX underlines is
the reason why you should not trust an
individual you should not trust a
company and instead you should trust the
code you should trust decentralized
protocols
and so that is why
um I want to say that although FTX is
certainly bad for the industry it is one
that we are going to recover from and
it's already in the process of
recovering from
um but the long-term prognosis for
digital assets and for crypto remains
strong and that is is something that
we're seeing ourselves as Venture
capitalists from talking to our own LPS
many of whom are big institutional
investors uh but also just seeing what's
going on in the markets and what's going
on in terms of kind of prices and demand
for investing into startups themselves
so
I don't have a ton of time left so I'm
going to try to move through fairly
quickly um so let's talk about ideas how
do you find a good idea the kernel of
every startup is the idea there's an old
saying in Silicon Valley that ideas
don't matter execution is everything uh
it's a little bit overstated but kind of
what it means that look you shouldn't be
secretive about ideas uh now what I mean
you shouldn't be secretive is that you
know ideas are hard to do anything with
uh meaning that if you tell a bunch
people about your idea
um you shouldn't be worried that
somebody's gonna go steal it and do it
better than you because it's very hard
to steal an idea and do it better than
somebody because ideas are a dime a
dozen ideas are everywhere there's so
many ideas that are out there the hard
thing is building an idea well now if
that doesn't mean that ideas don't
matter they do bad ideas will almost
inevitably lead to failure but good
ideas can very often lead to failure too
so the important thing is to find a good
idea and to test it from as many angles
as you can to understand it very deeply
and then to go and embrace it and go try
to build it into something great Okay so
um how do you find a good idea well
there are two ways to find an idea
generally one is through top-down
ideation and the others is through
bottom-up ideation okay I don't describe
each of them in turn so top-down
ideation top down basically takes a
bird's eye view imagine you're sort of
behind a veil of ignorance you don't
know who you are all you know is the
industry you know crypto
ask yourself what are the biggest
problems in the industry and sort of
break it down by verticals right you
might say okay what are the really big
problems today the really big problems
are that blockchains aren't private
that's a really big massive problem or
it's hard to monitor transactions that's
a really big problem tax compliance
required to pay your taxes in crypto
that's a big juicy unsolved hairy
problem okay then
you want to take those big problems and
figure out what is the total addressable
Market The Tam for each problem and what
is the total addressable Market a total
addressable Market is a way of trying to
measure
if I if there were a startup or a
company that solved this problem
what would be the potential pie that
could be earned by that startup right so
that you basically measure that in terms
of Revenue how much annualized revenue
could a startup build or in terms of
market capitalization how much market
cap if you sort of take that revenue and
and extend it by a multiple
um how big how valuable could a company
be if it solved this problem and earn
this much revenue every year so that's a
total addressable Market calculation
um usually these are done kind of back
in the napkin like these are not very
exact numbers that you're going to be
coming up with but it's important thing
to understand you know on a relative
basis at least looking at these
different problems which of these is the
biggest problem
because the biggest problem is going to
be able to
um sort of uh it's going to be able to
support the biggest company and have the
biggest prize if you build a star that
addresses that problem now when you're
looking at top-down education right so
you're looking at these big kind of uh
these big kind of loosely defined
problems and you're doing a tam
calculation for each of them
um you want to ask of course how crowded
is the area right so it's not enough to
say hey this is a big problem it's like
okay well how many other people are
trying to tackle this problem because if
I'm one of 40 people then I'm probably
not gonna be able to win but a very tiny
sliver of that pie but if this is not
very crowded if there aren't a lot of
people working on this then maybe I got
a good shot at being one of the big guys
who are going to solve this problem
the other thing you want to think about
is are there recent Innovations or
breakthroughs or technological
improvements that change the market
structure right or that change the way
in which somebody can tackle this market
so maybe yeah there were a lot of people
tackling this but that was two years ago
when we didn't have you know zero
knowledge proofs or whatever uh and now
that we do have them I can now create a
totally different approach to solving
this problem and that's going to unlock
this massive Market that wasn't there
before right so that's generally how you
want to be thinking about top-down
ideation start from the from the top uh
thousand for view of the industry look
down and try to figure out hey what's a
great startup I can build
the second approach is bottoms up and
Bottoms Up starts with you
not with the industry but with you what
is the area that you know best if you
don't know any area well then go spend
time in the industry and go figure out
you know what area do you have best or
what are the skills that you have what
are the relationships that you have what
are the experiences that you have that
are going to inform your ability to
build a great startup right so you're
sort of looking from your perspective up
okay from where I am where is my
connective tissue sort of what's my
breadth first search that I can find of
the you know the sort of most valuable
hot spots in the industry that I can
address for my own skill set so so what
feels like the biggest pain point from
your perspective
um and what's a product you know
oftentimes the way to do this is what's
a product that you wish that you could
use yourself and if so can you actually
build it right play to your advantages
find connections relationships
distribution that you can tap into given
your own experiences so this is bottoms
up ideation and usually when you build a
startup you want to do some combination
of both right you want to sort of take
some top-down understanding of how the
industry is structured but you also want
to look up and what are my skill sets
what am I good at the more experience
you have generally the more you should
tend toward Bottoms Up ideation because
you have a more differentiated skill set
you have more advantages that you should
be leaning into
um and the the sort of the earlier on in
your career you are the more you should
be thinking top down because you're not
tied to any skill sets and a lot of your
skill set you're going to gain through
actually building stuff yeah obviously
not always there are some products that
are very technical and require a deeper
set of experience before you can
actually build them but by and large
that's how you want to be thinking about
top down versus Bottoms Up ideation when
you're thinking about how to find a good
idea
okay now what are the features of a good
idea I'm gonna run through this pretty
quickly because we're running low on
time
um so first a big idea should solve a
big and clearly articulable problem okay
and clearly articulate is a very
important part of that one of the most
common mistakes that I see as a VC is a
Serta founder cannot explain the problem
they're solving it is not clear and
simple and easy to understand uh if it's
not clear and simple and easy to
understand then that means that it's
probably not a good idea
um second is that they should be
defensible they should possess emote and
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about what I mean by defensible in a
little bit
um but high level defensible means that
if you actually build something valuable
that you are going to be able to capture
value from what you build and it's not
just the case that anybody can come in
and copycat you or build the exact same
thing meaning that okay I solve this big
problem but I don't get to enjoy any of
the profits from actually solving the
problem
um should be easy to explain both to uh
customers to VCS and to your own
employees when you're trying to hire
people into your company
um
should have a very well defined customer
or user so I have a very clear why now
meaning that why doesn't this product
already exist why doesn't the startup
already exist why did it take until
today and you for this thing to start
working because of course before now it
didn't work right nobody built this
um so you should be able to understand
or explain to other people very clearly
why did it take until right now for this
company to get built and lastly you
should have strong value capture or
business model meaning you should be
able to gain High margins so let's talk
very quickly about solving a problem how
do you know this solves a problem first
you want to say why will users use this
product and what problem does it solve
and for whom if you cannot articulate
both parts of this who's going to use it
and what problem does it solve you're in
trouble okay second you want to think
about how bad is that problem is this a
nice to have or is this a must-have
right is this like well you know this is
this going to improve a little bit your
ability to do taxes on crypto that's
kind of nice but there are a bunch of
things that do that or is this like this
will be the end-to-end one product that
solves everything that you would
possibly have to do with crypto taxes
okay that makes it more like a must-have
than it nice to have the other thing to
understand is does it result directly in
cost savings for an individual or a
company or some other kind of utility
that's harder to quantify it's harder to
quantify generally speaking that's a
harder product to end up you know being
able to charge a lot of money for or to
gain a strong margin on
um but if it directly results in cost
savings that are easy to tell easy to
identify then it's generally a lot
easier to get customers and to get
people to be willing to pay for this
um now let's talk about defensibility
what makes something defensible or what
gives you a moat
generally speaking something that is
defensible or something that has a mode
is something that competitors cannot
easily enter your Market or overtake
your market share usually this entails
some kind of a network effect right
traditionally when we think of network
effects we think of something like
Facebook ethereum kind of like binance
which is you know an exchange like
coinbase these products are products
that the more people enter on one side
of the market uh or on any side right
the more people that enter the more
valuable it is for everybody involved
Facebook is a good example the more of
your friends on Facebook the better it
is to you on Facebook
um same thing with ethereum same thing
for an exchange like coinbase when it
comes to liquidity
um but it's not the only form of
defensibility other forms of
defensibility are economies of scale
meaning you are the cheaper it is to
produce whatever you're producing uh
pricing power you might have some
special relationship with a producer
um you might have a first move Advantage
you might be just be faster and be able
to iterate and execute faster than other
people
um cost of capital you could have access
to cheaper borrowing or cheaper Capital
than anybody else you could be access to
Talent if you're from Stanford you
probably have better access Talent than
other startups
um and the the weakest form of
defensibility is execution basically
meaning we will outwork you we will work
faster than you that's the the shittiest
form of defensibility because it's not
that defensible but in principle it can
be a way in which you have an advantage
over another startup and manage to
maintain your Edge in a market
so value capture
um I'm just going to skip through this
because I don't think we have so much
time to talk about it
um and then last lastly I want to talk
about the idea Mas okay
before you commit to an idea it is very
important that you study the idmas
another way is you need to study the
history of what came before you before
you actually go down building a
particular startup the the concept of
idea maze comes from biology srinivasan
used to be of course here at Stanford
um and uh here's here's the way that he
uh illustrates the idea maze this is the
idea Mas for
um you know music and P2P file sharing
I'll just read off what he says with
respect to the idmas he says a good
founder is capable of anticipating which
terms lead to treasure and which lead to
certain deaths a bad founder runs to the
entrance of the you know movies music
file sharing PDP maze or the photo
sharing maze without any sense of the
history of the industry the players in
the Maze the casualties of the past and
the technologies that are likely to move
walls and change assumptions okay so
what I mean by the idea Mas is that you
should study what came before you what
choices do they make what mistakes do
they make what what are the different
moves available to them in the Maze of
whether it's defy or you know uh or
under collateral lies lending or you
know uh staking startups or whatever it
is right if you don't understand what
came before you what were the choices
that were made by the previous people
who traversed the maze then you are
almost certainly guaranteed to repeat
their mistakes and so that's why it is
so important to spend the time to do the
archeology and figure it out whatever it
is that you're going to build in what
came before you build a very deep
understanding of it and be able to make
decisions learning from their mistakes
Building Services hard and if you don't
learn from who came before you it is
that much harder than what it has to be
so
um
end on some very common mistakes that I
see a lot of Founders make when they're
coming up with ideas
um the first thing is building for
customers who don't exist yet okay it's
very tempting to say well you know yeah
right now cryptos is a bunch of you know
a bunch of gens and it's a bunch of nft
flippers and whatever but I want to
build for the mainstream you know I want
to build for you know when my
grandmother is going to be using crypto
well your grandmother's not using crypto
today okay so if you build a product for
your grandmother then basically you're
building a product for someone who's not
here and somebody who's not here can I
give you feedback on your product
they're not going to use your product
they're not going to get any metrics on
them and startups need feedback feedback
is the oxygen that starts breathe if
they don't have feedback they can't
learn they can't iterate and that is the
life letter startups is learning
um another common mistake is solving
yesterday's problem rather than
tomorrow's problems right so you might
have looked and said man you know it was
so hard to you know when nfts were super
hot uh to be able to manage uh
whitelists right so I'm going to create
a whitelist management product well nfts
don't have that problem today the nfts
are much deeper problems than managing
whitelists so very common thing that
people will do is look back at what
problems they could identify previously
as opposed to looking forward to the
next two three four years and say what
are going to be the big problems then
when my startup is in its Heyday
um another very common mistake
blockchain for X if you build something
that's like blockchain blockchain for
oil or blockchain for you know uh the
the you know the advertising industry
um probably a bad idea please don't do
that
um building an unfriendly regulatory
jurisdictions sometimes this means the
US depending on what you're building but
you know something to be mindful of uh
and lastly building for crypto
influencers and this I just want to say
it's important to understand this
although crypto influencers are a lot of
who control the conversation
um they're a very small portion of the
overall people in crypto and the overall
customer base and they're very unlike
other people in the customer base
um so these numbers now are I made this
a long time ago there's probably an
order of magnitude off but you know
there are thousands of crypto
influencers out there but they're very
weird they're not normal people they're
not the kind of people who are going to
be using your products and so if you
build something because you think crypto
influencers are going to like it
um you're going to end up missing the
vast majority of what your users
actually care about and what they
actually want and so very very common
startup mistake is that somebody builds
something that a crypto influencer says
they want somebody says I want to have a
you know a homegrown uh Bitcoin node
that's built out of titanium that I can
have on my desk at all times that has no
parts that were built in China right
that's what some credit serverless as
they want guess what nobody else in the
world wants that just like that guy and
his two crazy cyberpunk friends so don't
make that mistake think very clearly
about who your customers are and who is
going to want your product and build for
a broader sense of what um you know
crypto customers and users are going to
care about so okay sorry I ran through a
lot of that content very quickly
um we've got about 10 minutes left and I
know you guys have some questions so I
will stop there and uh feel free to ask
whatever questions come to your mind
awesome
um thank you uh hussy for the detail and
awesome presentation so just um asking
the people in the classroom to have any
questions just raise your hand and pass
the mic to you
all right go for it
that's it
uh hello so thank you so much for the
lecture today and my question is that
like you mentioned that uh startup must
solve a problem and in your opinion what
is the main problem if you like
formulated that crypto in general solves
for like people
the great question what is the main
question that crypto solves for people
um if you take crypto on a very broad
basis right like when you say crypto you
just cryptocurrencies generally like
Bitcoin ethereum and Etc
um the the big problem that I would say
crypto solves is that crypto creates a
new kind of money that is usable for
different
that is much more open than money is
traditional okay
um there's there's a there's a concept
in economics known as permissionless
Innovation it's the idea that if you
want to innovate
that you do not need to ask anybody for
permission and get their approval okay
most kinds of innovation and finance are
very very permission right if you want
to build a new bank
you need to go get permission from the
OCC from your local fintech regulator
from you know the state
um State financial Regulators like
there's tons and tons and tons of things
that you do in order to decide I want to
build a new bank okay
but if you want to build an app
you don't need to get anyone's
permission
you just go build it you just you know
to go into your garage you cut up some
stuff you put on the internet and you
see jobs and you don't just ask anyone
hey is this good for the world it's a
good idea does this cause Financial
instability blah blah blah nobody is
going to ask you any of those questions
you just build it and see in the
marketplace of ideas who wins okay what
crypto does is it opens up that concept
to Mike it allows money to become in the
realm of permissionless innovation so
anybody whether they be you know a
stalwart like you know a very
experienced Banker or a financial
innovator or a company like PayPal or a
company like Visa or you know some uh
you know Ukrainian teenager
all of them are on the same Level
Playing Field to build a financial
application or find a financial use case
um and use money for it whether it's to
build a decentralized bank whether it's
to you know find some application that
that deeply integrates money or they can
send me to anywhere or anyone or even to
a non-human being which of course today
there's no way to give money to
something that's not a human being in
the traditional banking system but in
crypto you know it
any I can have money
a multitude of money a machine can have
money
um these concepts are very new
um and that's what I would say is the
critical problem that crypto solves is
that money today is too constrained and
crypto unbundles that money and allows
it to be used in novel ways
sure thank you good
thank you
all right yeah so my question is uh
slightly more personal so I was very
curious about your career as a poker
player so what sort of motivated you to
sort of shift out of Poker and enter
this field and if you had to like say
any learnings from Boca that you would
like us to learn I mean like overall
life lessons from Poco what would that
be
foreign
version so um I was a professional poker
player for when I was 16 years old until
I turned 21.
um I was sponsored made a lot of money
at a young age
um but I knew I didn't want to play the
poker for the rest of my life poker by
its nature is a zero-sum game obviously
and uh I I never liked the idea that I
was taking money from people who were
doing real things with their lives and
we're actually adding value to society
um and I was just better at a card game
that always wrote me the wrong way and
um I wanted to do something in my life
it was more intellectually
engaging but also was more valuable to
the world than Pope
um and so that's that's in large part
why I end up moving on from the game of
poker uh something I struggled with for
a very long time but um I was very happy
and much like that I did now what did I
learned from poker a tremendous amount
it's hard to
um it's hard to
uh
uh it's hard to boil that down into just
a few distillations but
probably the biggest thing that I'd say
I learned from poker is
to think
about the world clearly in terms of risk
and reward
Um poker player you learned that you
don't always get rewarded for making the
right play it's a very very deep Insight
in poker
um in general in poker it's often called
being results oriented
um you don't want to be result oriented
in crypto or sorry in poker results
oriented means that if one to assumed
that you did something right and if
you've lost you soon you did something
wrong but that's just not true and it's
not true if you live in a probabilistic
world that if you make the if you if you
make the right choice then you always
get rewarded for it right the opposite
is of course true that you may have done
something with positive expected value
but in the moment you end up losing
money because you know the Point Flip
didn't come your way or even though the
odds are in your favor it didn't work
out
um this understanding of risk is very
very important to one being a good
investor because of course it's very
often the case that uh you know it's
very obvious to see in poker that
sometimes you get your money in good or
let's say we go all in I have you know
Aces and you have you know uh tens right
well my hand is better than your hand
but I might sometimes lose 20 of the
time I'm gonna lose and so it might be
one of those 20 of the times in poker
it's very obvious that I see the right
play right I still made the correct
decision
um but in life it's we very often
try to convince ourselves that we don't
live in a probabilistic world and that
you know let's say that I make an
investment into a company and I think
hey I've got Aces I think this is a
great play but the company fails the
company fails for a very dramatic reason
I might then you know turn around and
say oh man I made a mistake I should
have seen it coming I should have known
this is the case well if if reality
actually is probabilistic and it looks
more like that poker game then even if I
make a great a great vision 20 time it
might not work out and when it doesn't
work out it might not work out for a
very random reason and that reason might
not be very instructive into how the
original decision was made and so that
kind of thinking it's not it's not you
know mind-blowing but that kind of
thinking doesn't come very naturally to
most people I've learned and for me
um it's very deep and intrinsic to the
way that I think about making decisions
um that allows me one to have a much
higher risk appetite than most people
and also to follow my
um to follow my judgment about risk and
reward much more easily than most people
and I think that that is something that
served me very well in life in making
different decisions that have led to me
coming to where I am today
thank you hi I wanted to thank you so
much for coming today
um I wanted to ask a question about Dows
and if you think that there's any
interesting opportunities there for
innovation
a good question
um so I have been a pretty vocal critic
of those over the last year now vows
have fallen a lot out of Vogue over the
last year so there's less to criticize
these days but of course last year you
know there was all this crazy dab Mania
where you know if you remember there was
Constitution Dao and all these other you
know link style and all these crazy
things where people are trying to buy
random stuff through crowdfunded Taps
um now that that has received a lot the
behavior is normalized and I think Dows
are in a little bit of a lull
um you know for the most part the way
that I think about Dao's is that Dows
are
those are hard
those are a very very steep trade-offs
that are you need to you there's there's
a big tax you pay in
uh using a dow to to do something
because Dows are slow
they are
um not very smart because of the fact
that they have to kind of Outsource
their intelligence and they rely on
disparate actors who generally have less
information than people who are very
close to the product
um but they get something for that tax
that they pay and that thing that they
get is legitimacy
um and of course the other aspects of
decentralization such as censorship
resistance and and uh you know the the
uh the ability to be more resilient if
one of the parties in the Dao is
attacked or is uh you know given a cease
and desist or whatever so
there are kinds of things that make
sense to build a tower up right so for
example
um maker now which is a decentralized
stable coin and uh you know credit
facility on chain that is the kind of
thing that makes sense for it to be a
doubt it makes sense for it to pay the
Dow tax
naked I was stupider because of the fact
that it's a doubt in the same way that a
democracy is stupider than something
that's not a democracy like California
is a great example of this right
California has this proposition system
it's a direct democracy uh which is
roughly analogous to how Dows were and
uh California does a lot of stupid stuff
because of this proposition system uh
because democracy is kind of dumb
because people are making these votes
are not thinking holistically about how
to best Shepherd
um an entire uh apparatus the way that a
you know a focused technocrat or
enlightened you know dictator might be
able to
um and the reason why most things in the
world don't structure as Dows or as
direct democracies right we don't
structure the Linux Foundation as a
direct democracy we don't structure
corporations that way we don't structure
families that way
um but we do structure states that way
and why do we see that way and we don't
look for corporations that way and I
think that question
uh I'm gonna end my answer there because
I think I actually I like making it a
little bit cryptic but I think that
question is a very important question
for us all as an industry to think about
is
um what are we getting out of
structuring things as doubts and what is
the cost that we're paying for that and
is what we're getting worth the cost
that we're paying so that was a very
obtuse answer to your question but um
given given that we're running up on
time I'm going to end my answer there
thank you uh for actually uh go going
over like already like 12 minutes of
your time
um thanks for sharing with us the class
your insights and uh the lecture
um thank you so much for the lecture and
for your time
yeah absolutely my pleasure yeah all
right thank you
everybody